hey guys it's Justine and today we're
gonna be checking out the brand new
iPads I am so excited because these come
in four amazing colors and one of those
colors happens to be pink I mean look at
this thing have you seen a more
beautiful thing no you haven't it's pink
I am absolutely obsessed with this color
it looks so so good there's actually a
few things in this new iPad that I've
been wanting in an iPhone for a long
time they have now decided to put USBC
in the new iPads which is pretty
exciting except for one thing because
these new iPads only work with the apple
pencil one and the apple pencil one is a
lightning connector so to use this apple
pencil with this iPad you will have to
use a tiny little adapter but if you do
have an old apple pencil one you will
need to buy the 9.99 adapter to be able
to use it with these iPads the thing
that I'm most excited about is they have
a landscape camera and they don't have
this on the pros so this is only on this
new version of the iPads so this is
going to be such a huge game changer for
doing conference calls and that is one
of the reasons that I was not able for
the past couple of years to be able to
use my iPad Pro as my main computer
because when I'm doing conference calls
and you're in this landscape mode having
the camera on the top is so not
convenient even with the new iPad Pros
they do have Center Stage but that M2 it
is still not on the top like these new
iPads so that's something that I'm kind
of upset about that they didn't do in
the Pro Models but if you do want the
landscape mode and these new colors then
this is the iPad for you these do have
the A14 bionic chip and like I said they
do have USBC and they also now have
Touch ID something that I've also really
been wanting in the iPhone but they did
bring it to the iPads now these are now
shipping with iPad OS 16 which is pretty
exciting because I have never actually
used it very much so now that I have the
new iPads I'm able to really test that
out there are two options that you can
choose from you can choose from the
Wi-Fi or the 5G version so depending
upon if you're going to be on the go and
you want to have the option of adding 5G
I would definitely recommend going with
the cellular version so you can always
have that option to upgrade obviously
with that there is a price increase but
the starting price for these iPads is
449. now the display is a 10.9 liquid
Retina Display and it goes up to 500
nits of brightness this obviously is one
of the lower end models so you're not
going to be getting the high-end HDR Pro
display that they have on the iPad Pros
I love for most people when you're just
doing Simple everyday tasks and also
using this for illustration or watching
content you're probably not really going
to notice that much of a difference so
it's seven millimeters thin and it
weighs about a pound so it is a little
bit lighter than the previous version
and a little bit thinner and of course
you have the apple pencil one and like I
said before piano pencil 2 does not work
with this iPad something else because
I've always been so accustomed to using
the iPad Pros is this doesn't have the
pro motion display so you may notice a
difference between even your newer
iPhones and the iPad Pros because it is
a little bit smoother of a display on
the higher end ones but for the most
part I do feel like a lot of people who
are using these are probably not really
going to notice that much once you go
promotion though I'm telling you man
it's pretty tough to go back so here's
the landscape check that out I can't
even tell you how excited I am about
this like this is probably my top
feature of this iPad I feel like I can
actually now use this as a dedicated
device for doing conference calls even
though it may not seem like a big deal
this is a huge deal this will actually
shoot 4K it is a 12 megapixel camera so
you aren't actually able to take photos
and do videos with this although it
still cracks me up seeing people
creating content with an iPad like it
just looks so silly even though these
can shoot incredibly high quality
content there's just something about it
that just looks super silly okay I'm
gonna take a little video with the iPad
4K content get hyped for it now when you
first get a device I do recommend going
in and changing some of the settings so
right now my settings are 1080 at 30
frames a second so we're going to change
to 4K 30 and we should be good to go
because a lot of times these aren't set
at that so you want to make sure you're
shooting at the highest possible quality
also does slo-mo 1080 120 and 240. look
at that hello peace sign okay but it
looks so huge on the screen like look at
that
hello it's me I'm Vlogging this is gonna
be my new Vlog lifestyle I'm gonna start
vlogging with the pink iPad it would be
pretty on brand though not gonna lie
okay let's take a photo here there you
go I like to call this my social media
hands
all right let's look at these photos
let's see what we got let's see what we
got this is quality content oh my God
the new set looks so good A little piggy
in the background live photo
Loop social media hands it actually
looks really good like I'm pretty
impressed like this looks super clear
is that has it been there the whole time
okay we're gonna move the chair I just
saw it in my photo something else that
is new they have this new iPad folio
case which looks super cool now you
might be like why is this coming into
pieces what's what's the deal so this is
kind of the back so this will just kind
of Pop right on like so and this allows
you to just kind of use this as a tablet
like completely plain normal everyday
what's up you look great if you want to
pop on the keyboard it has the SMART
connector right there at the bottom look
at that look at that now this is awesome
because this basically is turning this
iPad into like a mini little computer
now they've had the magic keyboard for a
while on the iPad pros and it has
completely changed everything for me I
feel like a broken record because I
continually keep saying how incredible
that magic keyboard is so I'm really
excited that they've kind of brought a
version of that to the regular iPad it
has an incredible keyboard it's a really
nice easy fun type plus it has a track
pad which is cool because it's a
different kind of way of using and
interacting with your iPad because it's
not actually like a mouse cursor it's
kind of like you're touching the screen
but you're not so you can see like the
the little cursor turns into sort of
this little circle and that allows you
to touch each of the icons so the
regular folio obviously doesn't have the
keyboard
so it is so crazy how that just comes
off so easily so with that SMART
connector it does allow you
to easily take that on and off now the
smartfolio I feel like is the way that
most people are gonna go with their
devices and you honestly can connect a
USB keyboard to these very very easily I
did a video a while ago talking about
the Logitech keyboards and some of those
keyboards allow you to connect the
Bluetooth to your iPad so basically if
you want a keyboard you can add a
keyboard oh look at that the mouse has
been connected okay now let's connect
the keyboard so in comparison to the
smart folio which is awesome it's really
really nice but it is
249 dollars which is basically half the
price
of the iPad I know so if you are wanting
a keyboard mouse combination and you
don't want to spend that much money you
can get this Logitech k380 and this
Logitech Pebble Mouse for what how much
did you say they were the mouse is 20
and the keyboard is 30 bucks 50 bucks
you can get both of these for 50 bucks
this is not sponsored I have previously
done a sponsored video for them but this
is not a part of the sponsored
integration I just genuinely actually
really like these keyboards so it's kind
of cool to see that there are other
options out there and that's not saying
that this is not a really incredible
device I mean for 249 dollars I mean I
honestly think that it you should take
me out on a date tonight I like pizza
and a Caesar salad and maybe a ginger
ale this keyboard mouse combo looks
great with the new blue iPad like check
that out
that looks fresh I'm gonna put this
luxury case back on because it's pretty
nice and I want to show you guys how it
types I like that you can
touch the display too like sometimes I'm
so accustomed to doing that because I
use my iPad so much that when I touch my
MacBook
I'm like what are you doing you can't do
that but it just just seems like you
should I also like the trackpad so this
does give you that option of you know
being able to do things like selecting
and clicking it's basically a track pad
on your iPad this does have landscape
stereo speakers so I'm going to watch a
little piece of content here to see how
it sounds another thing that I do like
about this keyboard is you can actually
control a lot of different things so you
can control the screen brightness you
can control the audio you can also put
it into Do Not Disturb mode and you can
search you can dictate so there are
various things that this keyboard can
allow you to do right now we're going to
listen to some content so I'm watching
Mythic Quest cool no it is cool though
because it provides an entirely new game
mechanic digging the players can now
literally change the landscape of the
game not bad apple needs a backstory
when I'm sitting here watching it
Gods themselves pretty good experience
okay let's test out procreates so here's
the USBC to lightning dongle so we're
gonna plug this in just like so we're
gonna plug in USBC here and then we plug
this in let it be known that I'm not a
fan of this but this is what it is I
guess it's better than this sticking
straight out of the laptop like previous
versions but this is what we need to do
to get it to work and to charge and to
connect so now let's see
let's write something oh look at that
look at this art like can you believe
how talented look at that that's just
some art right there so now there are a
few differences between the Apple
pencils this apple pencil obviously is
the apple pencil wand it is a little bit
shinier and on the apple pencil too it's
more of a matte kind of finish and this
will allow you to do gesture controls so
when you double tap you can have it do
things like undo or switch your brushes
this one does not have that feature and
it also is the glossy finish so I do
sometimes find that the apple pencil 2
is a little bit easier to hold but
drawing on this feels almost identical
to drawing with the two so I really
didn't feel like there was much of a
difference between the two still the
charging I just think it's it's so silly
and I don't really like it very much but
I do understand kind of coming from the
perspective of a lot of people already
have these apple pencil ones and they
may be the people that are upgrading to
these iPads so they still want to be
able to use this with their new iPad I
get it but I don't understand I don't
understand all right let's see if I can
find somebody to talk to me on FaceTime
this does have the new center stage and
wow do I love the landscape camera
already oh my goodness hi there's Bree
hi Brittany
well I'm in my studio because I work
here this is where I work do you like my
light
[Music]
let's do hi Jake here look what I have a
piggy it is a piggy do you want to give
the piggy a name
oh
kiwi kiwi the piggy do you know that I
used to have a hummingbird named kiwi um
do you think my video quality looks nice
let me
I turn you around you know what so I
have this new thing it's called Center
Stage so look when I run around
it'll follow me
look at that
do you like my office Bryn do you think
that you'll come visit me one day yeah
okay good
um well it was nice talking to you I'm
gonna go back to work now okay
okay bye I love you that was so chaotic
I'm not sure if that was the best demo
but either way that's what I feel like
kind of FaceTime normally is I could
already tell it just felt so much more
natural like this is the way the
orientation that the camera should be
when you're doing those types of calls A
lot of times during the pandemic because
I was using my iPad predominantly for a
lot of calls I would have to go
like this
so I'd be doing my conference calls like
that not quite ideal but it still worked
this is just such a better form factor
so super excited about this so I
definitely feel like this iPad is a big
upgrade from the previous gen the colors
are incredible so this iPad I kind of
feel like ranges somewhere in between
sort of a student and professional there
is a huge range of iPads right now so I
feel like if you're trying to choose
which one is right for you it is kind of
difficult because there are so many
different models there's so many
different versions what do you get I
think it really comes down to what do
you need and how much are you willing to
spend I do feel like this kind of comes
in at a pretty decent price range
starting at 449 but as you add on things
whether it's 5G or some extra storage
that is going to increase the price I do
feel like this is a pretty good iPad for
students or professionals who don't
really need the professionalness of an
iPad Pro you can still do illustrating
you can still do a lot of various things
on this where the iPad Mini may be
something that is geared towards
children so really this kind of checks a
lot of different boxes and the fact that
they do have these really pretty colors
is definitely something that I'm excited
about well thank you guys so much for
watching this was so much fun I'm so
excited there's some new iPads out I
also have some other videos unboxing
these and also a video on the iPad Pro
so be sure to check those out here on
the end screen and I will see you guys
in my next video don't forget to like
comment and subscribe and hit the Bell
to be notified when I post new videos
I'll see you guys in the next one bye
[Music]